Andy, how'd it go?
>> It wasn't too bad.
I got the cat clicker working.
>> [LAUGH] It wasn't too bad?
>> Yeah. >> Well okay, so what parts were more difficult for you?
>> It wasn't bad at all.
I mean, I was just, I'm just rusty with JavaScript.
I hadn't used it in awhile.
I'm used to Python syntax.
>> Okay. >> I was forgetting to declare my variables.
Forgetting semi colons.
And, I'm still just not very fluent with, you know,
manipulating the DOM through JavaScript.
So, there's a lot of Google searches to just figure out how to do
some pretty basic stuff.
>> Cool, but you got it working, overall?
>> I got it working, yep.
My div, with the cat ID, increments its count, when you click on it.
>> Awesome, good job.